hi my name is mike randa my name is  enrico cazarroza carlos lopez estrada my  name is  everybody i'm byron howard i'm jared  bush and we are here today to dissect a  scene from our movie we do a whole  caller script for the whole movie we  were quite careful to not set that many  scenes at sunset here the voice is  actually made by my wife it actually  kind of looked alike as well but i think  i remember every single time we saw it  we were like double the butterflies and  then we saw it again like this is way  too many we're like nope double it again  i don't know when else i would see  julian in in a disney movie they were  like you got one hoodie shot make it  count we're like what  [Music]  you